bonsoir quatrième et avant dernier débat
pour ces départemental le premier tour
aura lieu dimanche 22 mars et les
électeurs doivent élire un binôme de
candidats hommes femmes et nous
intéressons ce soir on compte de
saint-cyr-l'ecole un canton qui a été
redécoupée et qui comprend les communes
de saint cyr l'école bois d'arcy ville
prochain venez fontenay le fleury ou
encore rennes moulin les dernières
élections sur ce canton datait de 2000
ont sept candidats étaient en lice on va
retrouver certains sur ce plateau ce
soir et en 2011 le socialiste jean
philippe mallet l'avait emporté face au
maire ump de fontenay le fleury jean
jacques lasserre avec +2 58% des
suffrages alors en plateau ce soir pour
débattre sur ficc mais les bons soirs
c'est le conseiller général sortant vous
êtes candidat du parti socialiste et
vous êtes à associer pour ces élections
à fabienne j'ai le bon bilbo philippe
benassaya bonsoir mr de bois d'arcy
candidats union de la droite et vous
êtes associé à sonia bon et dalila
beaudry bon soit vous êtes associé à
jean yves maximilien vous formez la
liste agir
j'ai eu un bon soir du pour le front
national en binôme avec perrine genieau
et sylvia cantaluppi bonsoir vous êtes
associé avec christophe pitel pour
debout la france un petit rappel sur
l'organisation de ces élections
représentent front de gauche et europe
écologie les voilà c'est complet à
l'avant gauche europe ecologie les verts
un petit rappel sur l'organisation de
l'émission l'objectif évidemment c'est
vous que vous puissiez débattre votants
de paroles seront chronométrés pour
respecter une égalité de tentes pour
chacun ils s'afficheront régulièrement
pendant l'émission ma première question
ça va être un tour de table comment
convaincre les électeurs d'aller voter
les sondages annoncent une forte
abstention à peu près estimé à 58%
jugent
d'abord aux femmes je vois sida quand
elles ont pu lever les yeux au ciel que
dire aux électeurs pour loin pour les
convaincre d'aller voter dimanche 22
mars donc républicainement quand je vois
des taux d'abstention de ce niveau là je
me dis que quelque part c'est peut-être
les partis du système depuis 40 ans qui
ont fait ou mieux ou le pire mais enfin
qui ont tout fait pour décourager les
électeurs les leurres d'abord ensuite
les amours les encourager à l'or et pour
les encourager je peux dire que la
démocratie n'existe que lorsqu'on s'en
sert il faut toujours s'en servir
envoyer des messages forts il ya quand
même des candidats de différents partie
ya quand même moyen de dire des choses
si on n'est pas d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord mais ça sert à rien de baisser
les bras parce que c'est toujours
l'abstention sert toujours les sortants
d'aller à bahreïn même question alors
qu'est ce qu'on a envie de dire aux
électeurs
c'est que faut pas se tromper de faut
pas se tromper de scrutin que je les
souhaite que les acteurs soient déçus
par la politique nationale effectivement
ne vais pas voter pour ça y'a de quoi on
ne lisait pas voter pour une politique
d'austérité pour une politique libérale
et pour la montée du chômage et les
précarités donc aujourd'hui le scrutin
c'est un scrutin local qui touche au
plus près nos quotidiens donc c'est tout
c'est bien les solidarités c'est tous
les collèges la jeunesse est là sur les
sols des solidarités par nos congés
n'est rationnel donc c'est important de
se mobiliser pour ça pour ce scrutin là
il faut savoir pourquoi les français se
désintéressent de cette élection et je
veux dire pour après comment on peut les
mobiliser mais la première chose c'est
d'abord à ce qui s'y retrouvent pour
cette élection les médias nationaux non
on ne parle que du front national très
bien les baisses de l'état vers les
collectivités sont extrêmement
importantes ça aussi ça trouble le mille
feuilles administratif français est
extrêmement complexe il a été modifié
donc les gens ne s'y retrouvent pas il
faut être il faut être honnête et puis
et plusieurs déclarations de que ce soit
du président la république ou du premier
ministre qui souhaite la suppression du
conseil général notamment l'année
dernière il ya plusieurs déclarations
alors c'était tout ça fait que c'est
facile on n'incite pas vraiment les gens
à s'intéresser c'est dommage parce que
le département c'est coeur de la
république c'est le coeur de la
république et c'est le coeur de nos
attentes c'est le coeur de nos
préoccupations
et c'est dommage que tout ça soit
parasité parce que dès qu'on lance un
projet on se tourne vers conseil général
c'est primordial dans notre vie
quotidienne on verra les compétences
après on va en parler mais c'est très
important pour nos communes parce que le
binôme qui marche bien c'est le binôme
communes départements et dès qu'on lance
un projet c'est vrai je le vois moi même
dans ma ville à bercy dès qu'on lance un
projet on se tourne vers conseil général
mais malheureusement conseil
départemental maintenant et
malheureusement tout est parasitée par
un débat politique aux politiciens où
tout le monde mélange tout et forcément
les français ne s'y retrouvent pas j'ai
envie mais là vous êtes conseiller
général sortant vous sied au conseil
général départemental qu'est ce que vous
auriez envie aux électeurs de tradition
si vous regardez les résultats des
élections départementales au conseil
général depuis de nombreuses années les
traditions qui a un fort taux
d'abstention malheureusement il faut le
déplorer parce que tant de gens dans le
monde ne peuvent pas voter tant de
personnes ne vivent pas dans une
démocratie nous avons cette chance de
pouvoir voter régulièrement il faut il
faut s'en saisir et moi je dirais comme
comme argument la chose suivante c'est
que pierre bédier le président du
conseil général ump ump depuis très
longtemps le conseil général des
yvelines dit partout qu'il veut faire le
grand chelem donc moi je pose et c'est
pas possible le taux d'abstention je
pose la question aux yvelinois et je
pose la question aux yvelinois de gauche
est ce qu'il est bon pour la démocratie
locale qu'il y ait l'assemblée
départementale monocolore uniquement
représentée par des élus de droite à
majorité ump je ne pense pas que pour le
pluralisme politique ce soit une bonne
chose nous allons faire réagir dessus
après je passerai l'appareillage
huningue m comment vous réagissez ce que
dit jean philippe mallet alors est-ce
que c'est pas pour la démocratie faut
mieux avoir plus de certains partis
politiques avaient
elysée matignon le sénat l'assemblée
nationale et conseils généraux et des
conseils régionaux bon là ça n'a pas
choqué dans ce sens là alors forcément
je comprends jean philippe manesse et
c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils
réclament une pluralité des couleurs
c'est tout à fait dans l'important dans
tout cela c'est d'aller voter parce que
c'est encore une fois le coeur de la
république
oui bah l'abstention malheureusement ça
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui et on peut
dire que c'est aussi un peu la
conséquence de ce qui se passe depuis 30
ans c'est à dire l'alternance ps ump
c'est un peu la conséquence de tout ça
et les gens malheureusement sont
écoeurés ont l'impression que finalement
qui votent ps ou ump bah finalement ça
revient au même et on voit bien les
conséquences de cette politique voilà
donc nous on est là le front national
pour leur dire que non leurs voix
comptent ils doivent se faire entendre
les électeurs doivent voter et
effectivement nous sommes la seule
alternative à ce système ump s amener à
des questions plus politiques je filme
avec comment vous positionnez vous par
rapport à un binôme notamment union de
la droite qui a fait basculer la ville
de bois d'arcy donc une des villes du
canton dernières municipales philippe
benassaya sa légitimité de mer de bois
d'arcy à mon jeu n'était pas candidat à
cette élection municipale il a été élu
il me semble si je peux me permettre que
il est candidat rapidement après cette
élection municipale je veux que je lui
avais dit je désolé je pense que les
arcisien ont voté pour un maire qui tout
de suite après enchaîne sur une élection
départementale où c'est un choix
les arcisien
décideront et et donneront leur avis sur
sur le fait que quelqu'un qui a été élu
maire leur mère se présente de suite à
une élection à une autre élection
c'était trop tôt pour partir j'ai pas
choisi le calendrier en plus le
tripatouillage politique a été fait par
les amis de monsieur mal et donc c'est
pas moi qui ai choisi ce
timing là mais c'est pas grave dans ce
qui inquiète monsieur m'a laissé le fait
que tous les maires du canton de
soutiennent ça c'est ça c'est une c'est
une donne qui est qui et qui est qui et
concrète mais j'espère qu'on va venir
maintenant au fond
du problème
confirme tous les maires du canton
soutiennent plus jeunes à saillat il est
soutenu également par monsieur larcher
madame pécresse et monsieur bédié le
président du conseil général l'ump vous
avez tous les labos dry est ce que vous
avez pas peur avec votre liste notamment
au front de gauche europe ecologie les
verts de faire justement un peu d'ombré
à jean philippe mallet on est la seule
liste de gauche entière anti-austérité
alternative donc on défend nos idées on
défend notre position mais je représente
des candidats qui sont investis sur leur
commune de leur commune respective
en tant que haut niveau local en tant
qu'ailier où est élu d'opposition
on défend vraiment cette politique là
donc il s'agit pas de faire de l'ombre
ou pas c'est pas un problème 2
un moment faut bien défendre des valeurs
on propose une autre alternative est une
politique soit plus collaboratif qui
soit solidaire qui soit transparente il
sera transversale une fois que c'est on
appelle justement des conseils citoyens
ont donc fait des débats dans les débats
s'est s'associé ailleurs ea le temps des
expos et ailleurs mais ça cette lutte là
et ce mouvement là il continue et n'ont
donc pas droit aux candidats au conseil
des assurances et des idées ses valeurs
visiblement non on a une valeur commune
avec europe écologie sur le point de
tout ça va a été possible avec le parti
socialiste enfin on rentre voilà qu'à
part réussi à fédérer les forces de
gauche aux cantonales enfin 10 a plutôt
xive et voilà dans ma réponse est non
des signes et c'est très bien d'ailleurs
de faire une sphère présenter votre
candidature bon mais ne dites pas que
nous avons pas nous n'avons pas voulu
fédérer moi je déplore que la gauche
soit soit divisée parce que à ce petit
jeu gauche divisée c'est une droite une
assemblée départementale qui n'aura que
des élus de droite éventuelles et donc
c'est une responsabilité que vous avez
prises ce placement est déjà ump cette
assemblée justice qu'est ce qu'on fait
je vais te dire que c'est le moment
justement pour que les gens aillent
voter c'est le moment c'est la première
fois qu'on renouvelle totalement
l'assemblée donc la forme à clé 4 c'est
vraiment le temps de représenter toutes
les forces vives du département mais
pour de boules à prendre les venir au
secours des diamond
games au cours d'une liste de
l'expression démocratique
on a une élection à deux tours c'est
toujours comme ça au premier tour on
donne on fait de la priorité à ses
valeurs à ce qu on croit on défend les
valeurs profondes laquelle on croit de
ce conte à la tante etc au deuxième tour
souvent on élimine mais pour une fois un
premier tour c'est pour ça que on a
quand même là sur le plateau et à la
dispute et de nos concitoyens un choix
qui est raisonnable il n'y a pas
pléthore de candidats c'est pas
n'importe pas tout le monde de prendre
son petit étang da on a cinq positions
bien clair avec ça les habitants du
canton de saint cyr doit arriver à
trouver leur bonheur au premier tour au
deuxième tour il se passera ce qui se
passera mais au premier tour on a tous
les chéquiers et que et que les parties
seront mieux si j'ose dire il ya nommé
la pâte souvent il ya des candidatures
un peu farfelue la problème c'est clair
c'est net ils ont un choix il ya une
palette
n'y a pas de problème c'est là
l'expression de la démocratie et de la
république je vois pas où est le souci
je vous laisse là aussi la parole c'est
là qu'en tempo on vous a connu de toutes
les campagnes pratiquement pas est
souvent on fait souvent campagne la
république et la france c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur debout debout
la france anciennement debout la
république ses huit candidats sur 21
cantons comment on fait pour se faire
connaître mais nous on n'a pas de
problème pour se faire connaître parce
que nous avons choisi dans tous les
cantons des candidates étaient déjà
impliquées connu qu avait été candidat à
d'autres élections en plus nous sommes
un parti qui est encore jeune qui a pas
beaucoup de moyens donc tous les nos
militants sont sur le terrain sont de
toute façon même entre entre les
élections sur terrain ils sont connus
ils connaissent leur le leur vie les
connaissent leur canton entre nous on se
connaît on réagit non non il n'y a aucun
souci se met debout la france est comme
un martic est en progression constante à
toutes les élections ce qui n'est pas le
cas de tout le monde même si certains
partis crève le plafond par les
pourcentages les pourcentages ne veut
rien dire alors les pourcentages ne
veulent rien dire je passe la parole à
julien grimm les derniers sondages le
parti donc de marine le pen est crédité
de 21% des suffrages pour ces
départementale au niveau national devant
l'ump et le ps d'abord qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire et qu'est-ce comment vous
mener campagne eh bien ça confirme bien
déjà que le front national est bien le
premier parti de france on ne la vends
le symbole aae vu déjà avec les
élections européennes bon ben là on
continue sur on poursuit donc notre
montée est effectivement en plus je dois
dire qu'on est quand même assez aidé par
le gouvernement actuel qui nous facilite
la tâche malheureusement je devrais dire
mais effectivement on a toujours
l'impression qu'avec françois hollande
et manuel valls on va toucher le fond et
finalement et bien il arrive encore à
nous surprendre
quoi donc cette situation est
intolérable et et le problème c'est que
au niveau social ça commence vraiment
imposé de très très gros soucis quoi
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se retrouvent en situation de
précarité extrême
il ya le problème évidemment du chômage
mais il ya le problème aussi même des
gens qui travaillent en conditions de
précarité donc avec des temps pas si les
thèmes qui vous reviennent sur pendant
la campagne oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est
je veux dire c'est des thèmes très
important c'est normal c'est la vie des
français donc oui effectivement ça
revient assez souvent oui alors avant de
continuer ce débat on voit passer un
micro trottoir je voudrais d'abord que
l'on jette un coup d'oeil sur les temps
de parole de vous tous vous êtes a à peu
près à 20 secondes près en équilibre et
je vais effectivement concerner sur ce
micro temps nous sommes allés dans les
rues du canton demander ce que les gens
attendaient de leur conseiller
départemental on écoute et leur réponse
une plus grande solidarité envers les
notamment levé les personnes âgées
principalement c'est mal de monde comme
qu'on arrête d'agrandir saint cyr qu'on
revienne 30 ans en arrière avec de la
verdure qu'on aime qu'on évite de le
couper les arts de construire à tour de
bras ça serait quand même mieux quoi de
bien un peu de constructions mais un
petit peu de convivialité parce que
c'est vrai que chacun tout le monde
vient de paris chacun s'enferme chez soi
c'est c'est plus ça et puis améliorer le
réseau routier parce que là avec tout et
construction va pas pouvoir rouler
peut-être au niveau culturel ou acquis
et peut-être plus de chose faite pour la
jeunesse sentir il ya une association
qui s'appelle le ciré ados qui fait déjà
pas mal de choses mais c'est un petit
peu une ville morte du coup ce serait
peut-être bien de faire plus de choses
pour les jeunes voilà on dit qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui rôdent mais ce
qu'on s'occupe vraiment d'eux alors
maintenant parler des compétences
peut-être c'est difficile d'aller
convaincre des électeurs quand les
compétences sont en débat au parlement
dans la lignée de la réforme
territoriale la loi le nôtre a été voté
ce mardi à l'assemblée nationale alors
les conseillers généraux conservent
leurs compétences de solidarité d'être
social ainsi que les collèges les routes
perdent par exemple la gestion des
transports scolaires et puis surtout il
ya une clause de compétence générale qui
disparaît alors cela ne vous dit
peut-être rien mais cette clause elle
permettait un département d'intervenir
dans un champ qui ne relevaient pas
directement de sa compétence notamment
comme l'emploi ou le développement
économique c'est la région 1 qui
concentrera dorénavant ses pouvoirs en
la matière alors qu'en pensez vous
sur les compétences sur les compétences
hors la loi a été votée mardi à
l'assemblée nationale qui doit être il
faut encore attendre avant son corps
parce qu'il ya encore des navettes je
suppose des navettes parlementaires avec
le sénat absolument la soul à moi mr loi
qui a été votée non parce que je dirai
simplement sur les compétences du
conseil général c'est que encore une
fois comme je disais tout à l'heure le
conseil général répond aux attentes des
de la population notamment en matière
politique familiale seniors social
médico-social
le conseil général c'est le premier
acteur social de notre vie quotidienne
un bouclier social le fait que le
symbole qu'est ce que le conseil général
carte ses compétences sociales vient
vraiment fait mais question que le
conseil général perdent la clause de
compétence générale on peut en discuter
mais c'est un peu technique je pense
pour pour tout le monde mais je pense
que ce qui est très important c'est que
demain peut-être le conseil général
départemental ne pourra plus intervenir
en matière de des bleus développement et
dans le monde donc avec deux d'emploi
c'est non mais je rêve la politique
majoritaire du conseil général des
yvelines est quand même assez sans plus
je répondais à votre question concernant
concernant les compétences sociales donc
ça c'est la première ma première réponse
c'est sur le social c'est très important
que le conseil général garde cette cette
compétence ensuite il ya d'autres
compétences qu'on connaît la réussite
éducative les collèges il ya sans cesse
collège 116 collège pardon
départementaux dans les yvelines c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est un très
très gros budget il ya les transports il
ya le cadre de vie enfin il ya plein de
choses la réussite éducative le
numérique donc tout cela doit doit
rester et doit nous concerne et au
quotidien son film allait donc sur cette
loi notre qui a été voté mardi
l'assemblée nationale avoir toute une
navette avec le avec le sénat fasse un
vote parlementaire donc cette première
partie de l'eau alors la lumière mais ça
peut être un train d'édifier voilà il a
été dit tout à l'heure que sur le rôle
du département il y avait un couple
entre entre la commune et le département
j'irai pas tout à fait ça ce qui se
dégage de la volonté mais depuis de
nombreuses années qui traverse la droite
et la gauche s'il existe at her c'est de
faire fonctionner le couple communes
intercommunalités ce que l'on appelle le
bloc communal que les deux travaillent
ensemble et le couple département région
et c'est ce qui explique que pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de confusion entre le
département et la région on supprime la
clause de compétence générale pour kim
pour qu'on essaie qu'il y ait une bonne
articulation entre le département une
région
c'est pas que d'accord c'est vrai c'est
vrai dans les dents ça c'est la théorie
dans la dans la pratique oui de la
technique ou barré par exemple de la
technique mais qu'est ce que je vois
maintenant la mairie de bois d'arcy je
suis maire du bois d'arcy donc je le
vois c'est que le binôme alors c'est
peut-être dans la réalité c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être pas une
technique le binôme commune département
en département est primordial
aujourd'hui sur les projets je lance une
piste d'athlétisme je me tourne vers le
conseil général je lance une rénovation
du gymnase je me tourne vers le conseil
général donc c'est ça que je voulais
dire dans le binôme c'est que les
projets sont partagés
sur les fameuses complétant la loi danse
on a eu une ex majorité qui avait fait
fantasmer de supprimer les départements
la majorité suivante la supprime pas
lent retire des compétences enfin quand
je vous dis qu'ils sont souvent alliés
pour faire la même chose c'est priver
les français de leurs droits
d'expression et pour une fois qu'il ya
une compétence locale proche où il ya
encore quelque chose de proche par
rapport aux populations on supprime on
supprime des échauffements fait passer
des combes des compétences de la commune
aux communautés de communes du
département à la région est évidemment
la suite logique de tout ça c'est de
passer les cols à la souveraineté de
l'état à l'europe on déplace tout d'un
cran et du coup on déplace on éloigne
tout la démocratie des français la
prendra des airs refus ce qui est certes
yahia de l'abstention commencent à ce
serait les français n'acceptent pas que
où on balaye leur volonté ou on s'essuie
les pieds sur mme c'est déjà eu lieu une
réponse rapide
moi j'étais député lorsque manuel valls
dans son premier discours de politique
générale a annoncé à la france entière
que les départements allaient être
supprimés voilà tout à fait et donc on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
le cas pourquoi pas mais évidemment je
et je soutiens ce gouvernement même si
sur certaines lois je n'ai pas tous
voter mais on va bien la confusion que
kylie a auprès des français la
difficulté évidemment que l'on créé à la
bonne compréhension de cette réforme
vous avez beaucoup d'avancé
par les deux
infirmes territoriale qui est beaucoup
plus large que celle d'aujourd'hui ces
départements elle a touché aussi les
communes et communautés de communes à
terme l'idée c'est quand même d'éloigner
les centres de décisions des citoyens
donc c'est quand même et je crois que
c'est quand même assez étonnant passé
que ce soit l'ump au ps d'ailleurs
désolé de le dire mais c'est quand même
des décisions important qui
reconfigurent totalement la stratégie
par le
sera d'ici politique de la france et qui
est
redéfinie totalement les territoires les
centres de décision effectivement si
pour se rapprocher d'une régionalisation
qui se fait plaisir l'europe c'est pour
imposer une politique d'austérité c'est
pour imposer
sa politique libérale et c'est
et c'est surtout face à des décisions
enfin les froids phare le peuple les
français devraient être amenés à décider
de ça qu'on leur présente quelque chose
de général des réformes pourquoi pas
mais dès
qu'on leur donne demande leur avis par
des références c'est ça ça engage la
france sur les 6 restant elle-même y en
a quand même ce qu'il décide s'il reste
en tant que français et et qu'on
respecte la république
oui donc ça c'est qu'on a des
compétences ah oui les compétences et
malheureusement je crois qu'il y en aura
de moins en moins parce que là on est en
train d'assister un début de liquidation
du département c'est le but final c'est
de faire disparaître le département au
profit des régions ont fait disparaître
les communes au profit des
intercommunalités voilà on trouve le
prétexte de la mutualisation là on dit
que c'est très bien mais en fait on perd
complètement notre pouvoir de décision
au niveau local voilà c'est le but c'est
c'est comme ça et malheureusement on va
en payer le prix très bientôt donc et
encore une fois nous nous battons pour
le triptyque communes départements et 1
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez voir comme
compétence conservé par le département
il faut tout les conserver il faut même
les renforcer par exemple on a déjà les
collèges mais moi j'aimerais qu'on
récupère aussi les lycées
tout simplement c'est pour moi ça va
dans la logique des choses ça fait
partie du local et ça il faut que le
département et la main dessus
a dit oui enfin je pense qu'il ya un
moment
on a l'impression d'un millefeuille qui
s'écoute pour que les gens les les les
décisions s'éloigne de plus en plus de
citoyens donc le citoyen s'éloigne de
plus en plus de
des assemblées différentes qui pilotera
neg on en vient à ça c'est quand même
terrible de
mêlée france les français ont
l'impression que parfois ils votent et
que même quand ils votent ça sert à rien
parce que où les gens ont pas assez de
pouvoir ou pas de volonté ou pas de
crédibilité ou alors mieux quand le
peuple français expriment clairement où
ma bouée entre entre deux entre de
majorité et on se bat l'oeil les pieds
dessus et on se tient pas compte du
dernier référendum des lieux donc
comment voulez vous que les français
sentent motivés faut faut donner de
nouveaux élus avec de nouveaux partis
oui je suis très étonné d'entendre
représentant du front de gauche europe
ecologie les verts parlé de l'ump est
d'habitude c'est le front national qui
parle comme ça
sur cette politique libérale
on arrive à la moitié de cette émission
j'aurais même temps qu'on aborde
plusieurs thématiques d'abord la
solidarité de social vous passez la
parole d'aia bouderait vous dites la
politique sociale est minimaliste le
département qu'est-ce-qui oui alors
n'est pas
différent aussi solidarité sociale le
dernier thé c'est vraiment c'est les
politiques
républicaines nationale un des
dispositifs qui sont pris au niveau
national et navettes et
le rôle du département c'est de les
appliquer sur le territoire avec une au
plus près des gens au plus près des
besoins du jour avec
d'abord en les renforçant en mettant un
petit coup de pouce qui fait que ça
potentialiser ces aides et ça va et ça
permet aussi de
d'adapter localement parce que
j'apprends ton si ces difficultés là sur
le grand ton il ya une augmentation du
chômage augmentation de précarité on a
des z des choses qu'on n'avait pas ya
quelques années
donc il ya des problèmes de logement le
ciment social il ya un voile à ne pas
centraliser est trop de lancement sur
saint cyr mais aujourd'hui il ya plus de
logement social le conseil général a
financé 5 % des logements sociaux encore
ces logements sociaux et où on n'a
qu'une vie tu fais tout électrique les
gens peuvent plus payer leurs factures
donc un moment pour venir un petit peu
épais sur terre fait pragmatique il faut
vraiment répondre aux besoins des gens
juste une dernière chose sur le social
je suis très inquiète quand serait
inspiré même sur une enseigne at voix
aux
candidats ont parlé parlé de solidarité
se
la première source sur votre commune ça
a été de changer les quotients familiaux
vous avez quand même augmenté pour les
plus beaux augmenté de 5% après comment
comptent ils faire une vidéo sur les
services
services municipaux et vous avez baissé
de 15% pour les personnes les plus de
familles les plus favorisés donc je
crois que la ja nyan win a pas la
demande mais pas la même chose sur le
mot solidarité c'est surtout vous faites
de la politique un peu démagogique on
n'a pas c'est vrai on n'a rien eu c'est
faux on a fragilisé au contraire avant
qu'on arrive les quotients bas à payer
fort et les quotients au payer peu avant
qu'on arrive c'est le contraire
maintenant donc je vous encourage madame
parce que là c'est peut-être
là ça dépasse le département voilà voilà
je vous encourage
ce que je veux faire c'est que vous en
voyez je vais vous envoyer les quotients
de la ville de monarchie vous allez les
étudier et vous allez voir que on va
essayer ce soir sur ce plateau de sortir
de la politique politicienne pour parler
un petit peu du social c'est folie temps
réel mais madame le conseil
départemental qu'ils soient de droite ou
de gauche c'est du social
ces niches sociales
on ferme on z locales qui sont à oksibil
de la population
jean philippe malherbe pas sa part de
certains est ce que le conseil général
aujourd'hui attendant ce fait assez pour
le social ou pas d'une certaine façon on
ne fait jamais assez pour le social
c'est pas la question le conseil général
des yvelines a mis en place des habits
en place des politiques et d'ailleurs
pour la grande majorité de l'action
sociale qui relève du département vous
le savez bien ce sont des politiques
publiques qui dépendent de l'état quoi
qu'ils sont très encadrés par les temps
c'est bien techniquement c'est la
réalité l'allocation pour les personnes
âgées le rsa la prestation pour les
personnes handicapées donc tout ça est
extrêmement cadré part alors en dehors
de celles qui sont très encadrées est ce
qu'il ya des missions mais par wayne moi
je supportais par le conseil général en
matière sociale qui le sont pas
aujourd'hui mais je voulais en venir
c'est que le conseil général à hong kong
place des choses intéressantes en
matière de dette sociale en plus de ses
compétences l'autre est encadrée par
l'état par exemple un contrat sociaux
territoire on ne connaît pas assez et
qui fait que le conseil général à aider
les communes avec une approche globale
de chaque commune dans un bois d'arcy
fanti fleuri sur le canton ont signé de
tels contrats sociaux le territoire qui
aide les communes et les centres
communaux d'action sociale à mettre en
place des actions voilà des choses qu'on
ne peut pas critiquer de la part du lieu
du conseil général il ya plusieurs
personnes
plusieurs candidats sur ce jeu
sur ce
je passe mon tour
il vous avez deux minutes de retard sur
les autres
concernant les aides sociales c'est sûr
que l'on pourrait faire encore plus mais
effectivement fait pas forcément ce
qu'on veut non plus par contre je pense
qu'on peut arriver assez facilement
faire des économies on peut arriver à
faire des économies par exemple
par rapport aux dépenses de
communication paris mais aussi à trouver
de l'argent
oui oui
oui
sur le ton de la plaisanterie ce sont
les fameux compte de monsieur grimés qui
me plaisait beaucoup jusqu'à 12 ans
non tout ça pour dire que on peut on
peut trouver de l'argent il faut aussi
accentuer la lutte contre la fraude il y
en a marre de tous ces gens qui qui qui
qui se paye le rsa et qui font du
travail au black toute la journée toute
fraude
est-ce que sur le département des
yvelines vous avez par exemple des
chiffres à fournir est ce que vous avez
des données sur ce nombre de fraudeurs
est ce que ça représente ne serait-ce
qu'en pourcentage est passé 10% 20%
c'est vrai puisque puisque de toute
façon il ya très peu de contrôles donc
on est incapable de le quantifier on
sait rien on sait qu'elle est énorme et
effectivement on peut pas donner de
chiffre exact est l'énorme la fraude
rires ah ça non sur le témoignage
simplement
alors que je siège au conseil général
des yvelines il y a eu un débat un
moment tu as trop plus d'un an
sur sur le rsa et un conseil général de
droite bon est intervenu de façon très
démagogiques là dessus sur les fraudeurs
il y en a marre de payer les assister et
à très juste titre pierre front qui est
conseiller général maire de sartrouville
a vraiment un cadre et une chose en
disant que non en rétablissant les
choses il y avait ils avaient de la
fraude mais que tout ça est vraiment
très marginale dans les comptes publics
voulaient répondre oui ben non moi je ne
change pas mon point de vue pour moi il
ya de la fraude et il faut faire la
chasse si on n'a pas assez de gens qui
contrôlent effectivement on peut pas
vraiment estimer à combien et la fraude
effectivement un petit peu mieux
contrôler je suis pas sûr qu'à la marge
la différence soit énorme par contre il
y a des compétences dont le conseil
général des yvelines particulièrement ce
n'est pas le seul brésil il notamment
puisque c'est lui qui nous intéresse
quand on fait de la ce que j'appelle de
la délocalisation des aides qu'on va
faire des aides à l'international et que
ça chiffrent par millions depuis des
années je pense que relocaliser les
aides et celui des yvelinois d'avoir une
aide de proximité en département si
quelque chose de près et en plus pour le
coup on attend
on intervient dans notre champ d'action
d'une prérogative de l'état parce que
l'aide internationale c'est l'état qui
doit faire c'est pas une région ni même
à département qui n'en a pas les moyens
puisque a contrario on diminue certaines
aides et on fait disparaître des péni d
où on donne pas c -à-d certains ehpad
des choses de proximité qui intéresse
directement des yvelinois vous êtes tous
à peu près 4 minutes 30 de temps de
parole sont générés vous avez minutes de
retard je vous laisse une minute sur wii
on peut pas si social sur le social et
la solidarité
moi j'aimerais revenir un petit peu sur
le conseil général vont tout à l'heure
monsieur mal est donc bien expliqué
qu'effectivement il y avait une majorité
ump donc au sein du conseil général moi
moi j'aimerais parler un peu des
problèmes d'éthique voir un peu de
morale quoi voilà on a actuellement
monsieur pierre bédier président du
conseil général ok
c'est fini c'est un argument
effectivement si qui a été condamné pour
corruption passive quand même qu a eu
quand même trois ans d'inéligibilité
pardon et puis alors je rappelle que
père miani n'est pas sur ce plateau pour
se défendre ou non alors d'accord
d'accord mais il est quand même
président du conseil général oui donc
moi moi ça sera temps pour seulement
trois mois ça me pose un problème
personnellement voyez ça vous
personnalisé que ce soit pierre bédier x
ou y c'est une question générale nous à
debout la france voulait tic en vie
politique c'est aussi l'art c'est
l'hyper de l'ong ces avis de tous les
élus condamnés
anastasia genre est ce que vous avez en
garde réponse est passé avant lui de
défendre pierre bellanger mais je vais
pas mais au niveau effectivement la
question mais dans les données résident
les visibilités d'âge mental d'un élu
qui a été condamné non mais moi je a
purgé sa peine pour achever mon voisin
du front national de faire d'être très
discret surtout quand on a un président
d'honneur du parti qui a été condamné
une dizaine de fois par la justice
monsieur le pen donc dans ces cas là
vous n'avez pas de centre de données
voilà condamnés pour rappel jusqu'à
pierre bédier quand même derrière ces
élections commencent à 140 c'est même
pire donc 9 1 mois je vous le dis ce qui
est très intéressant lorsqu'on est sur
un plateau et lorsqu'on c'est de
défendre des projets vous l'avez fait
jusqu'à maintenant c'est de défendre des
projets et de voir ce qui peut avancer
dans ce département j'entends beaucoup
de discussions très négative mais après
on s'étonne que les gens ne vais pas
voter si on les décourage à longueur de
journée avec des sujets de qui ne
concerne pas le département les gens
n'iront pas voter sans fil mais au delà
des questions de personnes qui sont
importantes et qui existe c'est pour ça
que moi j'insiste et je pourrais vous
donner les discours que je fais dans les
réunions publiques c'est sur
l'importance de l'état on a fait la
décentralisation le gouvernement de
gauche françois mitterrand gaston
defferre ont fait les grandes lois de
décentralisation il fallait donner voix
au chapitre aux élus locaux c'est
important mais on voit bien les dérives
du système on voit bien les limites du
système les baronnies locales les fiefs
et qui nuisent à l'intérêt général au
péréquation aux solidarités entre
territoires donc il faut toujours posé
des règles et des interdits et c'est à
l'état de le faire donc vous vous auriez
été favorable à ce que un élu qui a été
condamné ne soit plus par exemple il
faut voir si juridiquement c'est
possible il faut voir ça précisément
mais oui sur le principe comme ça je
suis tout à fait favorable
alors quand on parle d'éthique serait
quand même bien qu'on a nous en tant que
candidat on a signé une charte citoyenne
sur tout et qu'elle visite sur notre
bloc on s'est engagé à pâques hume et au
non cumul des mandats va faire de plus
de deux mandats successifs et toujours
rendre compte de toute façon au citoyen
de l'action qu'on peut faire et toujours
être en interaction avec les citoyens
dans les collectifs locaux crois que
c'est important alors après voilà pas
excusez moi ce que
j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne sur le
social et sur le prendre comme ça qu
important parce qu'il ya des
déclarations d'intention puis à la
réalité tiens j'ai fait donc je pars les
quotients familiaux et alors il ya sans
doute des collaborations d'espagne entre
le département et les communes faune et
flore et la première première décision
du maire supprimer toutes les hawks et
les aides ménagères pour les personnes
âgées voilà donc c'est voilà la réalité
sur le terrain c'est une famille en
difficulté mais qui demande de l'aide si
sa demande est plus de six mois pour
avoir un éducateur qui viennent aider en
milieu ouvert donc ça c'est ces réalités
là c'est là la selas et les couper parce
que vous êtes un peu longue au niveau de
ton tant que j'aurai le sourire qu'on
aborde le derby système est d'accord
c'est que en fait il ya des déclarations
d'intention et en fait dans les faits
comme si une majorité sortante on peut
aussi les juger même si une demande
suivie de rejoindre une majorité vous
siégez pas on peut peut-être dire que
vous êtes innocent mais en tout cas
pourquoi pas vous
cela veut dire t il ya un bilan mondial
très bien mais l'incident sur ce sujet
là y compris à gauche sur les gens qui
sont condamnés qu'ils ne supportent pas
les condamner non non ça vous parlez pas
de championnat les jeux par des
déclarations d'intention sur le social
oui le mais justement je parle des
ou en fait il ya eu un ensemble de
choses qui sont prévues dès des
suppressions de pm xterra dont on l'a
des interventions de louables et en fait
non donc c'est la cdu alors quand vous
parlez de projets de vouloir nettoyer la
vie politique et d'avoir des attentions
sur le renouvellement et le
l'élargissement des partis représentés
dans l'assemblée c'est un projet parce
que c'est porteur de citoyenneté et
c'est un projet je suis désolé on peux
pas vous laisser dire ça dizaine de
minutes d'émission on va afficher vos
temps de parole vous êtes tous à peu
près à 5,30 je vous félicite à
l'exception de julien green qui a
toujours une minute de retard on va
maintenant parler des de l'environnement
et des transports en commun quand on
traverse le canton de saint cyr ce qu'on
remarque c'est que les routes sont très
encombrés à bercy de vénissieux mais
c'est une réalité et à saint-cyr-l'ecole
aussi qu'est ce que peut faire le
conseil général notamment pour les
routes et aussi pour l'environnement
qu'est ce que peut faire le conseil
général la tiare globalement de
transport oui bah bien sûr on peut on
peut trouver moyen de renforcer les
lignes de bus ou le stand
by élevé le projet tangentielle qui va
arriver ça va sûrement soulagé au niveau
de la ligne l'acce sacyr saint-germain
bon bah voilà après après c'est sûr que
au niveau 2 des transports ont fait pas
forcément ce qu'on veut
et bon il ya différents facteurs à
prendre en compte mais il me semble que
sur le canton de saint cyr dans
l'immédiat c'est assez délicat je fais
pas moins de faire un duplex où je sais
pas trouvé un une promettre quelque
chose de complètement délirant mais
sinon
duplex
peut-être des projets qui n'ont sans
doute pas aussi
sur l'un des transports l'environnement
mais en fait c'est vrai qu'on a un
canton complètement saturée en plus la
disposition géographique fait qu'il ya
une communication entre la peine
versailles et le plateau et que pour le
coup bien que ce soit monsieur de la crs
ou d'autres il n'y a pas de ja paille on
peut pas faire grand chose il ya eu
quand même des projets un peu faire à
mon humble avis de faire une percée
entre le rond-point de ville pourrait
remonter encore à bois d'arcy histoire
de re saturés puisque je vais vous
manqué non mais je pense effectivement
la seule solution serait peut-être
d'abord d'arrêter une de temps en temps
de trop densifier l'habitat à certains
endroits parce que là il ya un moment on
arrive à une limite et puis
effectivement de
fluidifier les s'appelle le transport en
commun sap et un aménagement de voies
entre autres une chose les circulations
douces on n'en parle pas mais on manque
singulièrement de pistes cyclables
tout à fait d'accord avec madame
cantaluppi il ya plusieurs problèmes
d'abord concrètement il ya un problème
qui impacte nos villes que ce soit
passant de saint cyr en allant à bois
d'arcy vers fontenay et donc vers
villepreux et donc tout le canton c'est
la rd 127 c'est rd 127 que semer les
connais aussi qu'on appelle nous a
menacé la rupture peau qui est
totalement saturé
il faut être concret c'est vrai que si
on densifie l'urbanisme c'est vrai on
aura des problèmes c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai été élu maire j'ai supprimé projet
de coeur de ville à bois d'arcy qui
était un projet de 400 logements parce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu
supporter tout ça mais ce qui est très
important et sur d'autres sujets aussi
c'est la mutualisation des moyens il
faut à tout prix que les villes
travaillent ensemble et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il faut être faut être
honnête on travaille bien ensemble mais
pas assez je prends un exemple si je si
j'ai dix secondes encore un exemple de
ce matin moi je suis allé au forum de
intercommunaux intercommunal de l'emploi
a fondé fleury qui est organisé par
contre même et avec le partenariat doit
darcis de saint cyr sur l'emploi des
jeunes notamment c'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est ce qu'il faut faire sur la
rd 127 et c'est ce qu'on a fait déjà et
ses opérations en tous de coopération
par exemple la piscine aussi de saint
cyr aujourd'hui aussi maintenant on a
des partenariats avec la mairie qui nous
permettent de travailler ensemble c'est
ça qui est à voir trois films oui tout à
fait non mais les preuves noir sur le
canton à l'intérieur du canton rd 127 à
bois d'arcy rd7 à saint cyr l'école r
les 11 à fond qu ils fleurissent un
dossier que je crois bien connaître je
me suis vraiment engagés et impliqués il
y a une équipe très importante qui a été
financée par la fois le conseil général
et les maires de versailles grand parc
très importante une étude avec vraiment
des spécialistes
il n'y a pas de solution miracle mal
malheureusement ce qui se détachent ce
qui se détache c'est évidemment
favoriser la construction de voies en
site propre pour les transports en
commun ce n'est pas toujours possible
techniquement mais moi j'ai le souvenir
par exemple il ya certaines rues qui
sont quand même mais bien la reja ça y'a
un réseau aussi philippe benassaya a
raison aussi d'attirer l'attention sur
le fait qu'il faut que les mères
travaillent ensemble moi j'ai le
souvenir très clairement
pour retrouver ça dans votre archive
jean jacques lasserre le maire de
fontaine jury qui a été un grands mères
proposé que entre fond de pury et saint
cyr l'école puisque personne ne voulait
la construction vous savez du
contournement il ne reste vraiment
pratiquement que ça des voies en site
propre jean jacques lasserre maire de
fontenay-le-fleury avait proposé de
construire sur la voie qui va jusqu'à
saint cyr l'école une voie en site
propre le maire de saint cyr l'école ne
le voulait pas donc il ya à la fois des
problèmes techniques vraiment pour
trouver des solutions et puis aussi il
faut que les maires mais moi je joue un
chacun c'est à ces contraintes que les
mères travaillent ensemble et puis
effectivement ça a été dit pardon sur
les transports quelque chose de très
important j'ai porté les délibérations
au conseil général c'est la tangentielle
ouest quoi qui dans la relation domicile
travail au quotidien et avancent les
événements qui avance doucement mais le
conseil général s'est impliqué là dessus
avec la région et l'étape contrat de
plan etat-région inscrit les
financements sont acquis la volaille
alors sur lui aussi parlé
d'environnement
parce que je sais que ça c'est les alors
c'était effectivement ses rangs il faut
qu'on sorte du tout voiture on voit bien
que tout a été fait pour tout voiture là
sur notre canton il faut en sortir
aujourd'hui rond il ya eu 4 alerte
pollution aux particules fines sur le
sur le canton sur le département en une
semaine en un mois on n'a jamais eu
autant donc
effectivement c'est le résultat des
constructions anarchiques du tout
logement
sur les quelles villes principales
villes pour eux une refonte est saint
cyr bois d'arcy alors j'ai eues on a
travaillé sur le cette étude 1 2 qui a
été fait par le conseil général qui
était sûrement très intéressant
effectivement
la collaboration entre les maires c'est
comment se déplacer les gens arrivent en
bas ils ont à la gare ils bondissent et
ils ont au collage et tous ses points
forts ils vont les fraudes sur les
points sur les endroits commerciaux il
faut qu'ils décident propre il faut que
tu as un bus en site propre qui
desservent la gare de saint cyr l'école
qui est une des plus importantes au
niveau du département surtout qu'elle
subit
il faut il ya la guerre de villepreux la
guerre de fontenay aussi et si axa qui
pourra réduire les battures si on ne
fait plus de route ce sera plus de
voitures et plus de traversier des du
compte encore qu'on arrive à le travail
on arrive à la fin à la fin
on arrive à la fin de cette émission
vous êtes tous à peu près au même niveau
sur julien green qui aime décidément est
en retard je voudrais dernier tour de
table sur sur les conclusions vous
voudriez aparté pour convaincre de voter
pour vous cela par vous avez une minute
largement d'avant surtout mais allez-y
ce que j'aimerais dire c'est que toutes
les élections sont importantes mais le
22 et 29 mars c'est l'existence même de
notre département qui est en jeu nous
souhaitons renforcer le département et
le présenter dans sa ligue le préserver
pardon de sa liquidation prochaine voulu
par nos adversaires ump s
nous nous battons pour défendre la
justice sociale l'identité de la france
mais aussi lutter contre toute forme de
communautarisme
c'est ainsi que nous garantirons l'unité
de la république voilà il n'ya qu'une
seule alternative possible c'est le
front national
je laisser la parole matin vos
adversaires même ps comme vous les avez
appelé philippe bana saillants en
quelques secondes pour en tant que
candidat de l'ump s
j'ai quelque chose j'ai pas mal de
choses à dire
d'abord se recentrer sur les compétences
du conseil général on n'est pas là pour
faire campagne présidentielle
le premier point c'est que je les dis
tout à leur département c'est le coeur
de la république le coeur de la
république date est défendu depuis la
révolution française le département n'a
jamais évolué n'a pas eu et n'a pas
bougé la région a bougé pas le
département pourquoi parce que le
département c'est notre proximité et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller voter il
faut pas se plaindre après 6,6 si on
n'obtient pas les aides si on va pas
voter il faut aller voter parce que il
faut voter pour nos préoccupations
quotidiennes il faut le faire avec il
faut le faire avec passion aussi c'est
quelque chose qui intéresse les gens
même si il ya des vents contraires dans
les médias etc kinki désengage un peu
les français de cette élection je pense
que cette élection est primordial il
faut voter pour les compétences du
département et c'est ça qui est
important j'ai un fils mais je voulais
c'est une quarantaine de secondes bien
depuis très longtemps conseil général
des yvelines est dirigée par l'ump avec
une majorité écrasante
je rappelle que nous étions dans la
dernière mandature neuf conseillers
généraux de gauche sur 39 un quart donc
j'appelle vraiment
les électeurs de ce canton du canton de
saint cyr l'école et les électeurs de
gauche évidemment bien considérer de ne
pas laisser cette assemblée
départementale uniquement aux mains de
l'ump permettait un élu de gauche
pardon de de faire entendre une voix de
gauche au conseil général de façon à
jouer un rôle d'aiguillon de proposition
et quand cela est nécessaire et bien de
de critiquer
la gestion la gestion du département par
par l'ump vous avez une minute
à lyon ce qui est important c'est de se
dire qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux on
est quand même entre autres sur le
canton sur une vingtaine de versailles a
beaucoup de choses à développer au
niveau tourisme éco tourisme
environnement il ya de qualité de vie un
truc c'est important c'est quand même
pas besoin de vivre ensemble c'est
refaire recréer du lien social c'est au
niveau des communes c'est aussi au
niveau du département et ça il ya
beaucoup on y réfléchit c'est aux
citoyens de se saisir de ça alors je
crois qu'on a une opportunité là c'est
de renverser 7 à 107 ans conseil général
ump c'est les gens sont en rente de
situation depuis des décennies et voilà
il va falloir renouveler pour redonner
un renouveau et pivoter pour les gens
qui y ont aidé et défendre nos valeurs
quant à nous de bien évidemment il faut
que tous les citoyens à aller voter
parce que j'ai toujours important de
donner son avis et de se sentir concerné
par des sources aussi proche par contre
effectivement je pense qu'il ne faut pas
donner une majorité uniforme à ce
conseil général pour autant nous à
debout la france la droite et la gauche
on estime que leur propre clivages il
est pas là par contre en tant que
république à voter pour des conseillers
généraux qui vont éclairer la majorité
quelle qu'elle soit une majorité écrire
et doit pas être unique or c'était la
fin de c'était la dernière phrase de ce
débat merci beaucoup à vous sans dettes
ni sur pato téléphiles débattre autour
du canton de saint cyr l'école on va
revoir votant une dernière fois vous
êtes tous à peu près en même temps sauf
junien grippe décidément voilà je vous
aurais donné la parole vous avez
toujours une petite minute de retard je
vous rappelle que le premier tour
évidemment des élections départementales
c'est le dimanche 22 mars et ce débat
sera à nouveau diffusée ce samedi à 10
heures et dimanche à 20 heures je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée surtout
aller voter